This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。绝对真人。百分之二。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析我们在这样一个陌生现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听“2%”。也就是数字“2”，可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子交往时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他将罪有应得。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《回看当年》播客。对于1979年来说，对我而言那是个重大时刻。84年对我意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及我们最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
欢迎在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回看当年》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不安全，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人身穿铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就非得这样做。欢迎在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《知难而进》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here. Back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we are going to talk about a relationship that is honestly like no other. It is unrivaled. It is a special kind of special and that is the one that we have with our pets. especially, but not just, but especially in our 20s, when they could honestly be a lifeline. You know, I've always loved animals. I've had such a soft spot for them. I'm an animal gal. I had pets growing up. I had an obese white rabbit for a long time. My childhood dog Yo-Yo is somehow still alive at 16 years old. God bless. I've always pet-sitted. I've always been around animals. But earlier this year, as some of you may know, I adopted my dog, Talu, and it feels like a whole new side of life has opened up for me,
大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到本期播客。无论你是新听众还是老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴有你在这里。欢迎收听新的一期节目，当然，我们照例要剖析二十岁的心理学。今天我们要聊的是一段坦白说独一无二的关系。它是无可匹敌的。它是一种特殊的特殊关系，那就是我们与宠物之间的关系。特别是，但不仅限于，尤其是在我们的二十岁，在这个时期，它们坦白说可能是我们的救命稻草。你知道，我一直很喜欢动物。我对它们有着特殊的软肋。我是个动物爱好者。我从小就养宠物。我曾养过一只肥胖的白兔很长时间。我童年时的狗狗悠悠不知怎么的，在16岁高龄时居然还活着。感谢上帝。我一直做宠物寄养。我身边一直都有动物。但今年早些时候，正如你们有些人可能知道的那样，我收养了我的狗狗塔露，感觉我的生活好像开启了全新的一页，
and it is really what made me want to do this episode today. It's going to sound wild. I truly did not realize how much I could love another living creature. I did not realize how much they could change how I saw the world. Like, the way I talk about her, I honestly sometimes feel like people think I have joined a new religion. It is genuinely like an unparalleled joy to walk through the door every day and like she is there and she is happy to see me the same way that it is, I'm sure, a joy for people to come home and their cat is there or their lizard or their bird. For so many of us, a pet is, it's more than an animal. And that's something I don't think you've understand until you have one of your own. They are a family member. They are a best friend.
这确实是我今天想要录制这期节目的原因。听起来可能很疯狂。我真的没有意识到自己可以如此深爱另一个有生命的生物。我没有意识到它们能如此彻底地改变我对世界的看法。比如，我谈论她的方式，坦白说，有时我觉得人们以为我加入了一个新宗教。每天一进家门，看到她就在那里，而且很高兴看到我，这种喜悦简直是无与伦比的，我相信这就像人们回家看到自己的猫、蜥蜴或鸟在那里时的喜悦一样。对我们许多人来说，宠物不仅仅是一只动物。这是你在拥有自己的宠物之前绝对不会真正理解的一点。它们是家庭成员。它们是最好的朋友。
They can pull us out of really hard times. They are a constant. and I know I could not imagine my life without her. But after I got Talu, I really started to wonder, like, why are they as special as they are? Like, how come I didn't feel this before? What makes her presence make me feel so much joy? Why is this bond so incredibly psychologically transformative? Basically, what is this human connection, an animal connection we have with these creatures that just kind of live in our house? Well, today, we're going to get into that exact science.
它们能把我们从极其艰难的时期中拉出来。它们是一种恒久的存在。我知道我无法想象没有她的生活。但在我收养了塔露之后，我真的开始纳闷，为什么它们的特殊性会如此之高？为什么我以前没有这种感觉？是什么让她的存在带给我如此多的快乐？为什么这种纽带在心理上如此具有变革性？简而言之，我们与这些只是寄居在我们屋檐下的生物之间，到底存在着怎样的人宠连接？今天，我们将深入探讨这背后的确切科学。
science behind this unique bond from the hormones to the neurotransmitters in our brain to the psychological needs they fulfill to how they change our lives and our brain chemistry. We're also going to touch on, in my opinion, one of the most painful and often misunderstood parts of pet ownership, which is the grief of losing them, something that I don't really see a lot of people talk about. We're going to talk about disenfranchised grief and how losing your childhood pet in your 20s can create a bit of an existential crisis and can be so uniquely heartbreaking. I want to apologize in advance. I'm going to be talking about my own dog so much throughout this episode because she is one of the loves of my life. So again, I am sorry,
探索这种独特纽带背后的科学，从荷尔蒙到我们大脑中的神经递质，再到它们满足的心理需求，以及它们如何改变我们的生活和大脑化学机制。我们还将探讨在我看来宠物饲养中最痛苦且经常被误解的部分之一，那就是失去它们的悲伤，这是我没怎么看到很多人讨论的话题。我们将探讨被剥夺权利的悲伤，以及在二十岁时失去童年的宠物如何引发某种存在主义危机，并带来如此独特的心碎感。我想提前道个歉。在这期节目的整个过程中，我会不断地谈论我自己的狗，因为她是我一生的挚爱之一。所以再次向大家道歉，
but I'm also not really, to be honest. She is the best. Hopefully you can like join me in my excitement, drop your pet's name down below, especially if it has like a human name. I want to know it. I'm really excited to further explore this with you guys. So without further ado, let's get into how pets change our lives. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more. to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
但说实话，其实我也并不是真的很抱歉。她是最棒的。希望你们能和我一起分享这份喜悦，在下方留言告诉我你宠物的名字，特别是如果它有一个人类名字的话。我很想知道。我真的很兴奋能与大家进一步探讨这个话题。闲话少说，让我们深入了解宠物是如何改变我们的生活的。“2%”。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析我们在这样一个陌生现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和体能专家等人进行对话。从而抛开那些充斥着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
我们曾坚信种子油本质上会导致发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听“2%”。也就是T-W-O-P-P-Cent，可在I-Hart Radio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与许多杰出的嘉宾展开了对话。我所说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此全身心地投入到追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西。而我们仍在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世界上做个好人很重要吗？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地去做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose. On my new podcast, learn the heart. Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。在我的新播客《知难而进》中。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《知难而进》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。由此开启了一场长达多年的法庭之战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Marantini.
桑兹女士，这份特定的检测报告你篡改过两次，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。这还没结束
until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
直到正义在亚利桑那州伸张。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《情陷局中》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands.
法则二，也千万不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《闺蜜》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子交往时。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己采取行动。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I told you guys there was going to be a lot of TALU content. I want to tell you the story about how I got her.
我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓我将成为他最后一个目标。他将罪有应得。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。我告诉过你们会有很多关于塔露的内容。我想讲讲我是怎么得到她的故事。
Not because anyone asked, but because I just want to talk about her. And I feel like it's a nice introduction to how I have seen a pet change my life in the last year. So not even the last year, in the last six months. So this is the story of how I got my cat. my love, my dog, my tarlou. So I made an episode almost a year ago now, which is wild, about a really hard mental health time I had when I basically just had like, I had a mental breakdown. I had a huge crisis. And at the time I was like in this really low point and I was like, I should really get a dog. Like I need something that's going to pull me out of this. I need, I need, like,
不是因为有人要求，而是因为我就是想谈论她。我觉得这也是一个很好的引子，让我看到宠物在过去一年里是如何改变我的生活。甚至还不到一年，是在过去六个月里。所以这就是我如何得到我的猫的故事。我的挚爱，我的狗，我的塔露。差不多一年前，我做了一期播客，现在想想觉得挺疯狂的，讲述了我经历的一段非常艰难的心理健康时期，当时我基本上就是崩溃了。我经历了一场巨大的危机。当时我处于非常低谷的状态，我就想：我真的应该养只狗。我需要有什么东西能把我从这种状态中拉出来。我需要，我需要，
this is the only thing I can imagine, like, it's going to sound really hard, but really wanting to be here for, like, I should get a pet. And I think they'll do, it will do a lot for me and really help me and, like, allow me to feel like there's meaning in the world again. So I kind of been uming and a RRing about it for a while before this moment. And I went to the RSPCA, went to the shelter. And I met a couple dogs. One dog who I really, really liked called Wolfie. So if you adopted a black German shepherd from RSPCA last year, whose name was Wolfie, hit me up. I hope she's doing well. And I kind of fell in love with that dog and I was like, you know what? This is not the right time. I'm a bit too young. I had a lot of travel coming up. I was living in like a house that like was not appropriate for a dog and I was like, this is kind of selfish.
这听起来可能真的很沉重，但真心想要留在这个世界上，为了它——我应该养个宠物。我想它们会做很多事情，它会对我产生很大帮助，并真正帮助我，让我觉得这个世界又有了意义。所以在这一刻到来之前，我纠结犹豫了好一阵子。我去了英国皇家防止虐待动物协会，去了收容所。我见了几只狗。其中有一只我非常非常喜欢的狗叫沃尔菲。所以如果你去年从RSPCA收养了一只名叫沃尔菲的黑色德国牧羊犬，联系我吧。希望她现在过得很好。我有点爱上了那只狗，然后我想：你知道吗？现在不是好时机。我还太年轻。我接下来有很多旅行安排。我住的地方根本不适合养狗，我觉得这样做有点自私。
I'm just going to wait and see how I feel in six months and we'll reassess. Six month mark came around and I was like, you know what? I'm still feeling this. I feel like I'm more prepared. I'm in a more stable place to perhaps have a pet. But I'm going to foster first. Like I'm going to foster an animal. I'm going to foster a couple of dogs and just give them like the chance to have a break from
我还是再等等看六个月后的感受，到时候再重新评估。六个月的期限到了，我想：你知道吗？我还是这种感觉。我觉得我准备得更充分了。我处于一个更稳定的状态，或许可以养宠物了。但我要先做寄养。我要寄养一只动物。我要寄养几只狗，给它们一个机会，让他们暂时脱离
the shelter, hopefully get them adopted, hopefully like use my platform so that other people can find their like fairy soulmate. And one of the dogs we fostered was Tarlu. Now Tarlu has a really sad backstory. She was in the pound for over a year. because and she was not allowed to leave the pound. She is like the most perfect dog. She is like a 40 kilo, what's that, like 80 pound math?
收容所，希望能帮它们找到领养家庭，希望能利用我的平台让其他人找到他们的灵魂伴侣。我们寄养的其中一只狗狗就是塔露。塔露有着非常悲惨的过往。她在收容所里待了一年多。因为她不被允许离开收容所。她简直是最完美的狗狗。她有大约40公斤，那是多少，大概80磅吧？
No, she's like 40 kilos. I'm sorry, if you're in America, you've got to do the conversion. I'm sorry. She's a huge dog. She's like this big black and white dog. No idea what breed she is. But she is like the most mild-mannered, gentle dog ever. I don't even think I've heard her bark, maybe once.
不，她大概有40公斤。抱歉，如果你在美国，你得自己换算一下。抱歉。她是一只大狗。她是一只这么大的黑白相间的狗。完全不知道她是什么品种。但她是我见过的脾气最温和、最温柔的狗。我甚至都没怎么听过她叫，可能就叫过一次。
She doesn't bark, she doesn't jump, she's fully trained. But she wasn't available for adoption because basically her previous owners had abused her and she had been removed from their care. And they had then sued the RSPCA or made an attempt to get her back until a judge had dismissed their case. Like had dismissed their right to her. And this poor puppy, like she's missing a bunch of her teeth. someone has obviously kicked her at some point. She has a massive burn on her nose.
她不叫，不跳，接受过完整的训练。但她当时不开放领养，主要是因为她以前的主人虐待过她，她被从他们身边解救了出来。然后他们起诉了RSPCA，或者试图把她要回去，直到法官驳回了他们的诉讼。驳回了他们对她的所有权。这只可怜的小狗，她缺了好几颗牙。很显然有人曾经踢过她。她的鼻子上有个巨大的烧伤疤痕。
We first got her and I remember being in the car and turning to Tom, my boyfriend, and being like, oh, I really think we've made a mistake, as in like we're not giving this dog back. But I said to him, I was very clear. I was like, we are not making a decision for three months. If someone comes along and adopts her in this three month period, that's their dog. She's so wonderful. She's so amazing. But that's their dog.
我们刚把她接回来时，我还记得在车里转过身对汤姆——我的男朋友说：“哦，我真的觉得我们犯了一个错误，意思是说我们不会把这只狗还回去了。”但我对他说得很清楚。我说：“我们在三个月内不做任何决定。如果在这三个月里有人来收养她，那她就是别人的狗。她太棒了。她太迷人了。但那是别人的狗。”
And a couple of people were interested. but they would see how big she was. They would make assumptions about her character. They wanted a puppy. They wanted whatever. And they would like would never follow through. And so the three month mark came around. Literally the three month mark was the same day that my book came out. And I don't know if you guys know this, but my book came out and I moved house within 24 hours and we adopted Talu on the same day. Because the three month mark came around and I was like, this is my dog. Like this is my dog. And she is literally everything to me. I spend almost 24 hours a day with her.
有好几个人表示了兴趣。但当他们看到她体型那么大时。他们就会对她的性格做出假设。他们想要小狗。他们想要别的什么。然后他们就从来没有真正付诸行动。于是三个月期限到了。字面意义上，三个月期限的当天正好是我的书出版的日子。我不知道你们知不知道，我的书出版了，我还在24小时内搬了家，我们就在同一天收养了塔露。因为三个月期限到了，我觉得：这就是我的狗。这就是我的狗。她对我的意义极其重大。我几乎每天24小时都和她在一起。
I don't leave her for more than three hours a day. She does sleep in my bed. Some people are disgusted by this, but I just feel like she had such a tough life. Like, I don't know her whole story, but I know it was pretty terrible. And then she had to be in the shelter for a year. She had such a tough life.
我离开她的时间每天绝不超过三小时。她确实睡在我的床上。有些人对此感到恶心，但我只是觉得她经历过太悲惨的生活了。我不知道她完整的过去，但我知道相当糟糕。然后她又在收容所里待了一年。她经历了如此艰难的人生。
She's going to get whatever she wants. And now she's got like dual income, no kids. like that's me and Tom's situation. She gets whatever toy she wants. Yeah, we have dog gelato in our freezer. We don't have ice cream for ourselves. We have dog ice cream. She has outfits.
她想要什么都可以。现在她过上了双收入、不要孩子的生活——这就是我和汤姆的情况。她想要什么玩具都有。是的，我们的冰箱里有狗狗冰淇淋。我们自己没有冰淇淋吃。我们有狗狗冰淇淋。她有各种衣服。
You know, her dog bed is actually two dog beds on top of each other, like Princess and the Pea style. And this is really what brings me to this point. I've obviously changed her life. She has changed mine more. So what is it about having a pet? that is so completely transformative for so many of us. Well, it turns out it is not a singular thing.
你知道，她的狗窝实际上是两个叠在一起的狗窝，就像《豌豆公主》那样的风格。这正是我想说的重点。我显然改变了她的生活。而她对我的改变更大。那么，养宠物到底有什么魔力，
It is actually a whole cocktail of different things, of psychological and physical benefits, that come together to really improve our well-being and improve our development as humans. At the moment, loneliness is literally described as an epidemic, and social networks can feel fleeting, friendships can feel kind of surface level, we don't have as many opportunities to interact. Pets circumvent that. They provide a deep, constant connection that in times like these,
能对我们这么多人产生如此彻底的改变？好吧，事实证明这并非单一因素。这实际上是一系列心理和生理益处的完美结合，它们共同作用，真正提升了我们的幸福感，促进了我们作为人类的发展。目前，孤独感简直被描述为一种流行病，社交网络感觉转瞬即逝，友谊感觉有点流于表面，我们互动的机会没那么多了。宠物绕过了这一难题。它们提供了一种深厚、恒久的情感连接，而在这样的时代，
we kind of can't always find anywhere else. They're not going to go cold on you. They are not going to ignore your texts because they don't have phones, duh. Like, they simply show up and they love you for like exactly who you are that day. Studies consistently show that interacting with a pet, interacting with an animal in general, can reduce feelings of loneliness and increase feelings of social connection. Those are fundamental to our mental health. In fact, interacting with an animal is actually one of the most surefire ways of immediately having a positive emotion spike, of immediately feeling an improvement in your mood.
我们有时在其他地方根本找不到这种连接。它们不会对你冷淡。它们不会因为没有手机而忽略你的信息，废话。它们只是出现在那里，无论你当天是什么样，都爱你如初。研究持续表明，与宠物互动，与动物普遍互动，可以减少孤独感，增加社会连接感。这些对我们的心理健康至关重要。事实上，与动物互动确实是能瞬间产生积极情绪飙升、立即改善心情的最确凿的方法之一。
You know, in a world that is kind of unpredictable, a pet is this like anchor. This can provide us with like basically a psychological safety net. You might think, okay, even if my life is really stressful right now, even if there are people I can't trust, even if I feel disconnected, I always have this relationship. I have this source of comfort waiting for me at home. And sometimes that is the only reassurance that you need. Pets also give us this really clear sense of responsibility and routine, which is incredibly grounding when we kind of feel like life is sometimes losing a bit of its meaning or structure. For many, many people, you know, a pet is the reason they get up in the morning.
你知道，在这个有些不可预测的世界里，宠物就像是这样一个锚。这基本上可以为我们提供一个心理安全网。你可能会想，好吧，即使我现在的现实生活压力很大，即使有些我无法信任的人，即使我感到与世隔绝，我始终拥有这段关系。家里总有这样一份慰藉在等着我。有时，这就是你需要的全部安心。宠物还赋予了我们非常明确的责任感和规律的作息，当我们觉得生活有时正在失去一些意义或结构时，这种感觉会让人极其踏实。对许许多多的人来说，宠物就是他们早晨起床的理由。
It is one of the only reasons they may leave their house during the day. It is the reason they stick to a schedule. When you get a pet, like they are completely relying on you. I know that's super obvious to say, but they are super reliant on you. If it's a dog, like, you've got to feed them. You've got to give them water. You've got to walk them. You've got to brush them.
这是他们白天可能会出门的唯数不多的理由之一。这是他们坚持日程安排的原因。当你养了宠物，它们完全依赖于你。我知道这话听起来像废话，但它们确实超级依赖你。如果是一只狗，你得喂它。你得给它水。你得带它散步。你得给它梳毛。
You've got to play with them. You've got to give them mental stimulation. You've got to give the medication. Same with a guinea pig. Same with a bird, a rabbit, a lizard. I've never had a reptile. I don't really know. But I'm sure it's very, very similar.
你得陪它玩。你得给它提供精神刺激。你得给它喂药。豚鼠也是如此。鸟类、兔子、蜥蜴也是如此。我从来没养过爬行动物。我其实不太懂。但我确信非常非常相似。
Whether they have a good day or a bad day, whether they survive or thrive, whether they are happy, whether they are literally alive, all comes down to you. And that absolutely is a big and scary thought, but it also provides this feeling of structure and reliance that has actually been shown to combat symptoms of depression and anxiety. One study from 2018 found that this is particularly powerful for people really suffering with their mental health because there's something about another living creature needing you that is sometimes able to overcome the barriers that prevent us from taking care of ourselves.
无论是过得好还是坏，是勉强生存还是茁壮成长，是快乐，还是字面意义上的活着，全都要取决于你。这绝对是一个重大且让人有些害怕的想法，但它同时也提供了一种结构感和依赖感，已被证明能够切实对抗抑郁和焦虑的症状。2018年的一项研究发现，对于那些饱受心理健康问题困扰的人来说，这一点尤其强大，因为另一个有生命的生物对你的需求，某种程度上能够克服那些阻碍我们照顾自己的心理障碍。
People can be homeless, they can have extreme psychosis, and still, their pets are well taken care of, their pets are loved, trained, and fed. This psychological benefit is tied to a concept we talk about a lot on the podcast, self-efficacy. Caring for a pet just provides a very clear, tangible opportunity, for individuals to feel competent and to feel effective in their daily lives. The successful fulfillment of a pet's needs reinforces your belief in your own capabilities, which can be like a super powerful antidote when you're feeling helpless or feeling like, you know, I can't do anything.
人们可能会无家可归，可能会有极端的精神病症状，但即便如此，他们的宠物依然得到了很好的照顾、关爱、训练和喂养。这种心理益处与我们在播客中经常讨论的一个概念紧密相连，那就是自我效能感。照顾宠物为个人提供了一个非常清晰、切实的机会，让他们在日常生活中感受到自己的能力和效能。成功满足宠物的需求会强化你对自己能力的信念，当你感到无助或者觉得“我什么都做不了”时，这就像是一剂强有力的解药。
No one needs me. And in return for this reliance on us, pets give us this unconditional love that we talked about. They literally do not care who. you are, what you have done, how bad your day was, they continue to love you. And this level of adoration and love, that's pretty much unheard of in any other kind of relationship. Maybe like your family, but not always. Like no matter how you're feeling, it is this pure form of acceptance. pets, particularly dogs, I think, also serve as really powerful catalysts. Like we already talked about loneliness, but it's not just that their presence makes you feel
没有人需要我。作为对我们这种依赖的回报，宠物给予我们前面提到过的无条件爱意。它们根本不在乎你是谁，你做过什么，你今天过得有多糟糕，它们依然继续爱着你。这种程度的倾慕和爱意，在任何其他类型的人际关系中几乎是闻所未闻的。也许就像你的家人一样，但并不总是如此。无论你感觉如何，这都是一种纯粹的接纳。宠物，尤其是狗，我认为它们也充当了非常强有力的催化剂。就像我们刚才讨论的孤独感，但这不仅在于它们的存在能让你感到
less lonely. It's that they also are kind of an inn to a social life beyond just them of other dog owners. You know, bringing a dog to the park or on a walk. The amount of people that you talk to, it creates such amazing avenues for social. social connection. The amount of intention you get when you're out doing life with your fairy little companion in the wild is crazy. Like any time I take Tarlow anywhere, I am guaranteed to talk to at least five people. I also, I have literal dog park friends now. I have drinks with them at the park on Thursdays. We all bring our little cans of beer and our little cans of
不再那么孤独。还在于它们其实是你融入超越宠物本身的更广泛社交生活（比如通过其他狗主人）的切入点。你知道，带狗去公园或散步。你与之交谈的人数之多，为社交互动创造了如此惊人的途径。当你带着毛茸茸的小伙伴在现实世界中体验生活时，你受到的关注度简直疯狂。比如无论我把塔露带到哪里，我保证至少能和五个人说话。而且我现在有了名副其实的狗公园朋友。我们周四会在公园里一起喝一杯。我们都带着自己的小罐啤酒和小罐
wine. And when we run out of things to talk about, guess what? You just talk about your dog. You just start watching what they're doing. You don't even have to say anything. It basically provides a prepackaged, low effort route into conversations with people. Those are the social and mental health benefits. The physical benefits of this companionship are also pretty obvious. You know, I've talked about dogs a lot. They are the most common owned animal. I'm fairly sure, domesticated owned animal. But dog owners actually tend to be more physically active. They tend to have a higher step count. And that also contributes to better emotional well-being. The combination of movement and social interaction and purpose-driven movement as well.
葡萄酒。当我们的聊天话题用尽时，你猜怎么着？你只需谈论你的狗。你只需开始观察它们在做什么。你甚至不需要开口说话。它基本上为你提供了一条打包好的、低成本的切入对话的途径。这些是社交和心理健康方面的益处。这种陪伴带来的生理益处其实也很明显。你知道，我谈了很多关于狗的话题。它们是最常见的家养动物。我相当确信是驯养宠物中最常见的。但狗主人实际上往往体力活动更多。他们的步数往往更高。这也促成了更好的情感健康。运动、社交互动以及以目标为导向的运动相结合，
Like I'm doing something for someone else, for something else, makes them feel better in their daily lives. Let's also talk about why this pet human bond is really, really unique and not something that we can just dismiss as like, oh, it's just because they rely on you. It's so much more. In some ways, you know, it's kind of similar to the relationships you would have of the family member. I'm going to go as far as to say that. But I think the key difference is the fact that there is an absence of complex communication. And there is an absence of just complexity in general that can sometimes make other kinds of social connections feel really burdensome.
就像我在为别人、为另一个生命做某件事一样，让他们在日常生活中感觉更好。我们来聊聊为什么人宠之间的这种纽带是极其独特的，而不仅仅是“哦，这只是因为它们依赖你”这种可以轻易打发的理由。远不止于此。在某些方面，它有点类似于你与家庭成员的关系。我要这么说。但我认为关键的区别在于缺乏复杂的沟通。并且通常缺乏那种有时会让其他类型的人际关系感到极其沉重的复杂性。
To really understand this, we kind of have to rewind a little bit. our relationship with animals was not always this warm and fuzzy for thousands of years like it was all about work the whole human animal bond basically started as like a mutually beneficial business partnership over 20,000 years ago maybe I think it's between 15 and 20,000 years ago we're trying to find a pinpoint if we look at how our relationship with dogs has come about for example the ancestors of our modern dogs ancient wolves probably started hanging out near campsites or small communities to snag leftover food. Now, the ones who weren't completely terrified of us,
要真正理解这一点，我们得把时间稍微倒回一点。我们与动物的关系并不总是像现在这样温暖而温馨的，在数千年的时间里，这完全是关于工作整个人类与动物的关系基本上始于2万多年前的一种互利商业伙伴关系，也许我认为是在1.5万到2万年前之间，我们正试图找出确切的时间点，如果我们看看我们与狗的关系是如何演变的，例如，我们现代狗的祖先——古代狼，可能开始在营地或小社区附近闲逛，以伺机抢夺吃剩的食物。现在，那些对我们并非完全感到恐惧的狼，
they had a serious advantage because guess what? They could get closer. They could integrate easier. They could become a favorite. And in return for getting little bites of food that we didn't want, these dogs became a built-in alarm system against predators, against other tribes. It was a trade.
它们占据了严重的优势，因为你猜怎么着？它们可以靠得更近。它们可以更容易地融入。它们可以成为宠儿。作为获得我们不需要的零碎食物的回报，这些狗变成了抵御捕食者和其他部落的内置报警系统。这是一场交易。
Over thousands of years, through a process of both natural and artificial selection, dogs were then bred for specific behavioral traits, like vigilance, like tameness, and then later for things like hunting, hurting, and guarding. And also just like being really cute. It was only much more recently in the last few centuries that, you know, their role did actually shift from working animal
在数千年的时间里，通过自然选择和人工选择的双重过程，狗被繁育出特定的行为特征，比如警惕性、驯服性，后来又被用于狩猎、牧羊和看家护院。以及单纯的“长得非常可爱”。直到最近几个世纪，它们的角色才真正从工作动物
to cherished family member. Although there is evidence of like, really deep emotional bonds all the way back like 12,000 years. I actually found this article from, I think it was the Smithsonian from a group of archaeologists who found evidence of ancient people likely caring for a sick and domesticated puppy for weeks on end before it died. After it died, the dog was then buried with the remains of another dog and an adult man and woman, making it not only the oldest burial of a domesticated dog on record, but also the oldest known grave to contain both dogs and people. So when you look at a dog's deep loyalty today, you are seeing an echo of thousands and thousands of years of a working partnership that is now transformed into just pure love.
转变为受人喜爱的家庭成员。尽管有证据表明，深厚的情感纽带甚至可以追溯到1.2万年前。我实际上发现了史密森尼学会的一篇文章，来自一组考古学家，他们发现了古代人类可能在多达几周的时间里持续照顾一只生病的被驯养的小狗直到它死去的证据。在它死后，这只狗与另一只狗以及一个成年男女的遗骸埋葬在一起，这不仅使它成为有记录以来最古老的被驯养狗的葬礼，也是已知包含狗和人类的最古老墓穴。因此，当你今天看到狗的忠诚时，你看到的是经历了数千年工作伙伴关系的延续，这种关系如今已经转化为了纯粹的爱。
Cats, they have a different origin story. They were originally solitary hunters. But they also totally figured out that our new farms were packed with rodents. So they just started showing up where we kept our grain, where we kept our harvest. They were great for natural pest control and we basically just let them do their thing. Like dogs, the cats that were more docile and tolerant of people were more successful. But unlike dogs, cats' domestication process, it was less of like an artificial selection process and more of a natural adaptation to like the humans that they were coexisting with. Basically, cats have
猫有着不同的起源故事。它们最初是独居猎手。但它们也完全弄清楚了我们新开辟的农场里到处都是啮齿动物。所以它们开始出现在我们存放谷物和收成的地方。它们是天然的灭害能手，我们基本上就随它们去了。就像狗一样，那些更温顺、对人类更宽容的猫更容易生存。但与狗不同的是，猫的驯养过程较少是一个人工选择的过程，而更多是对与其共存的人类的一种自然适应。基本上，猫已经
domesticated themselves, which I don't think is surprising at all considering their independent nature. But basically, you know, we've gone from you work for me to, you're nice to have around to your family. Like, I'm going to buy you clothes. I'm going to buy you nicer food than I do, than I eat. I'm going to let you sleep in my bed. Like, literally when we first, brought Tarlu home. She wouldn't eat normal dog food because I think she was just stressed and overwhelmed new environment. And so my boyfriend Tom one day, he brought home organic chicken mince. Meanwhile, we had generic chicken mints in the fridge for us to eat. But Tarlu, she got the $15 chicken mints. She got the princess treatment. Honestly, sidebar, if you want confirmation,
自我驯化了，考虑到它们独立的性格，我觉得这一点一点也不令人意外。但基本上，我们已经从“你为我工作”演变到了“你在身边挺好的”，再到“你是我的家人”。比如，我要给你买衣服。我要给你买比我自己吃的还要好的食物。我要让你睡在我的床上。比如，字面意义上，当我们刚把塔露接回家时。她不肯吃普通的狗粮，因为我觉得她当时对新环境感到压力重重、不知所措。所以有一天，我的男朋友汤姆带回了有机鸡绞肉。与此同时，我们冰箱里还有供我们自己吃的普通鸡绞肉。但塔露，她吃上了15美元的鸡绞肉。她受到了公主般的待遇。老实说，顺便说一句，如果你想确认
you're dating the right person or your partner is going to be a good parent. If you want be a parent, just see how well they treat your pets. Like it is such a great litmus test. Like Tom is obsessed with her and it has made me love him so much more. This profound sense of companionship, it's also no accident. It's also no accident that Tom fell in love with Talu. It is very easy to link our relationship to our pets with the release of oxytocin. Oxytocin known as the love hormone known as the cuddle chemical. Obviously, yeah, they're fluffy. and they give us love and they cuddle us. But research from 2015 even shows that
你在和对的人约会，或者你的伴侣会是一个好父母。如果你想成为父母，只要看看他们如何对待你的宠物就行了。这绝对是一个极好的试金石。比如汤姆对她着迷不已，这让我更加深爱他。这种强烈的陪伴感也绝非偶然。汤姆爱上塔露也绝非偶然。我们与宠物建立关系与催产素的释放有着非常直接的联系。催产素被称为爱情荷尔蒙，也被称为拥抱化学物质。很显然，是的，它们毛茸茸的，
when dogs and their owners gaze into each other's eyes, both experience a surge in oxytocin, similar to that between humans and infants. Everyone always says, like, oh, my dog is like my baby. Literal evidence of that. This biochemical reinforcement, it creates a feedback loop of attachment and bonding.
它们给予我们爱并拥抱我们。但2015年的研究甚至表明，当狗和它们的主人凝视彼此的眼睛时，双方的催产素水平都会激增，这与人类和婴儿之间的互动类似。每个人总是说：“哦，我的狗就像我的宝宝一样。”这就是字面上的证据。这种生化强化创造了一个依恋和结合的反馈循环。
It solidifies the very unique nature of the relationship. And there's a truly, fascinating detail of this that perfectly illustrates our kind of co-evolution. Did you know, puppy dog eyes are actually not a natural wolf trait? Research from a 2019 study published in the proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences found that domestic dogs have a small muscle in their eyes that wolves, they don't even have and they have never had. This muscle allows dogs to basically raise their inner eyebrow, creating the classic like puppy dog eyes. So this movement, it actually makes their eyes look bigger.
它巩固了这种关系的独特本质。这里有一个真正迷人的细节，完美地说明了我们的共同进化。你知道吗？小狗那楚楚可怜的眼神其实并不是天然的狼的特征。2019年发表在《美国国家科学院院刊》上的一项研究发现，家养狗的眼睛里有一块小肌肉，而狼甚至没有这块肌肉，过去也从未有过。这块肌肉使狗基本上能够抬起它们的内眉，创造出经典的小狗式眼神。因此，这种动作实际上使它们的眼睛看起来更大。
It makes them look more infant-like, which in turn triggers a nurturing and caregiving response in humans. They literally have taught themselves how to look like a baby. This study suggests as well that the dogs who had the more expressive eyebrows had a selective advantage because they looked cuter, so they were more likely to be cared for, fed, adopted by humans, and they passed that trade on. This has actually been referred to as not survival of the fittest, survival of the cutest. And it is a powerful example of how dog's facial anatomy has been shaped by literally evolving to tug on our heartstrings. Pets also,
这使它们看起来更像婴儿，进而触发了人类的抚育和照顾反应。它们简直是自学了如何看起来像个婴儿。这项研究还表明，拥有更多表现力眉毛的狗具有选择优势，因为它们看起来更可爱，因此更有可能得到人类的照顾、喂养和收养，并将这一特征传给后代。这实际上被称为“不是适者生存，而是最萌者生存”。这是狗的面部解剖结构如何通过进化来触动我们心弦的一个有力例证。宠物还，
this is another little known fact, they offer a form of co-regulation for our nervous systems, similar to the kind of co-regulation we sometimes find with other humans. When we pet an animal, our heart rate actually slows down. Our stress response reduces, cortisol levels reduce, decrease, sorry, and we enter a calmer, more regulated state. A study on an animal visitation program amongst university students found that the simple act of petting a dog around exam time, reduced cortisol levels,
这是另一个鲜为人知的事实，它们为我们的神经系统提供了一种共调节的形式，类似于我们在其他人类身上有时能找到的共调节。当我们抚摸动物时，我们的心率实际上会减慢。我们的应激反应降低，皮质醇水平下降，抱歉，并进入一个更平静、更受调节的状态。一项针对大学生动物探访计划的研究发现，在考试期间仅仅抚摸一只狗这个简单的动作，就能降低皮质醇水平，
and greatly increased feelings of support. And pets, it's not just a passive thing. Like, they don't just passively make you calm. They also mirror our emotional states. This was something I was so surprised to find out. But also not. Like, I've kind of seen this happen with me and my dog. You know when you've had, like, a really bad day at work?
并大大增加支持感。而且宠物的作用不只是被动的。它们不仅仅是被动地让你平静下来。它们还会映射我们的情绪状态。这是让我感到非常惊讶的一点。但也并不完全意外。因为我多少在自己和我的狗身上看到过这种情况发生。你知道当你经历了一次诸事不顺的工作日时，
And then your dog, like, just lies by your side for a cuddle. Like, they just know that you need it. Research shows that dogs are actually masters at reading our emotional cues. they combine information from our body language, vocal tones, facial expression, even our scent to understand how we're feeling. There was a recent study done in 2024 that found that dogs can detect subtle changes in our breath and our sweat that indicate stress with over 90% accuracy. Like a dog can literally smell when you're having a bad day.
然后你的狗就会静静地躺在你身边求抱抱。就像，它们就是知道你需要这个。研究表明，狗其实是解读我们情绪线索的大师。它们结合来自我们肢体语言、声调、面部表情甚至气味的信息来理解我们的感受。2024年的一项最新研究发现，狗能够以超过90%的准确率检测出我们呼吸和汗液中表明压力的微妙变化。就像狗真的能闻出你今天过得不好一样。
And this like kind of creates the basis for the emotional mirroring or like the emotional or contagion that we're talking about, where they catch our feelings and they reflect them back. Now, on a good day, this creates a really reciprocal loop of positive energy. Like, I'm happy, you're happy, I'm happy, you're happy, just gets better and better. But that can just as easily reflect our stress or our anxiety or our sadness. A 2019 study published in the journal Nature found that dogs' long-term stress levels often sink up with their owners, showing that our emotional state has a very real impact on our own pets cortisol levels and their own, I guess, mental well-being.
这为我们所讨论的情感镜像或情绪传染奠定了基础，在这种情况下，它们感知到我们的情绪并将其反射回来。好了，在状态良好的一天，这会创造一个非常互惠的正能量循环。比如，我很开心，你也很开心，我很开心，你也很开心，情况会变得越来越好。但这同样也很容易反映出我们的压力、焦虑或悲伤。2019年发表在《自然》杂志上的一项研究发现，狗的长期压力水平往往与它们的主人同步，这表明我们的情绪状态对我们宠物自身的皮质醇水平以及它们自身的心理健康产生了非常真实的影响。
But this unique reciprocal regulation where they calm us and our calm presence in return calms them, it is what creates this symbiotic bond that is truly unlike any other. The therapeutic power of this connection is so significant. It is a core component of animal-based therapy where animals are used to help people with their anxiety, with their PTSD, with other mental health challenges, with an astounding success rate. Research also shows that therapy dogs can reduce anxiety and stress greatly in educational and medical settings
但这种独特的双向调节机制——它们能抚慰我们，而我们平静的存在反过来也能抚慰它们，正是这种机制创造了这种真正独一无二的共生纽带。这种联系的治疗力量是如此巨大。它是动物辅助治疗的核心部分，动物被用来帮助人们应对焦虑、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）以及其他心理健康挑战，并取得了惊人的成功率。研究还表明，治疗犬可以大大降低教育和医疗环境中的焦虑和压力
to help children undergo procedures, help them get vaccines, all these other things. Not just dogs, the same goes with horses. If you have the time, look into the relationship between horses, and individuals with autism. It will blow your mind. Like we don't have the time to get into it.
帮助儿童经历各种医疗程序、接种疫苗以及所有这些其他事情。不仅仅是狗，马也是如此。如果你有时间，了解一下马与自闭症患者之间的关系。这会让你大开眼界。就像我们没有时间深入探讨一样。
But when I was researching this episode, I went into a complete rabbit hole. It is like honestly beautiful. There was like one video, one story that made me cry. So that's what you're in for. And I just think it shows like this relationship is literally healing people. It's not just companionship. So we're going to take a short break here.
但当我研究这一集时，我彻底陷入了一个未知的世界。老实说，这真的很美。有一个视频、一个故事让我哭了。所以这就是你将要经历的。我只是觉得这表明这种关系实际上是在治愈人们。这不仅仅是陪伴。所以我们要在这里稍事休息。
but when we return, we are going to talk about some of the saddaparts about owning a pet and talk about the heartbreaking reality of losing your childhood pet, losing a pet in general, losing your companion and your best friend and how that elicits a pain that a lot of people don't understand, but which is very, very real. So stick with us. We'll be right back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an estimated.
但当我们回来时，我们将讨论养宠物的一些悲伤部分，并谈论失去童年宠物、一般意义上的失去宠物、失去你的伴侣和最好的朋友的心碎现实，以及这如何引发许多人不理解但却非常非常真实的痛苦。所以请继续关注我们。休息片刻后，我们马上回来。百分之二。这就是当也有估计时走楼梯的人数比例。
escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
有自动扶梯可用。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些困难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人的身份从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。即I-Hart广播应用、苹果播客或你获取内容的任何地方上的TWO-Percent。
podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我所说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐了
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了那个东西。而我们仍然在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于胜利和失败。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在地球上时做一个好人很重要。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能成为一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《硬核学习》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
打开你免费的I-Heart广播应用。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的不一致之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战的序幕，以证明真相。你在这某人的检测中作假了两次，对吗？我作假了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我想让人们看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷g（Greg）、一个女同性恋者以及迈克尔·马林奇尼（Michael Marincini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。在IHeart广播应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两个黄金法则。法则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hip-hift. by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get
法则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这个新季的《女朋友们》中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以他们决定亲自动手。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到
what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Given the in-depth bond of this relationship that we have with our pets, one of the most agonizing experiences can be when we lose them. And it actually elicits something that psychologists call disenfranchised grief. The term disenfranchised grief, it was coined by Dr. Kenneth Docker, to describe a kind of pain that isn't necessarily socially sanctioned, it isn't necessarily openly acknowledged or publicly supported, but it is very much real.
他应得的。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。鉴于我们与宠物之间这种深厚的联系，最痛苦的经历之一莫اعات当属失去它们。这实际上引发了一种心理学家称之为“被剥夺的悲伤”（disenfranchised grief）的现象。“被剥夺的悲伤”这个词是由肯尼斯·多卡（Kenneth Doka）博士提出的，用来描述一种不一定被社会认可、不一定被公开承认或公众支持，但却非常真实的痛苦。
It is a kind of grief that society tells us, like, we don't have the right to feel. So we're kind of forced to mourn, mourn in silence. You might hear distant friends or colleagues say things like, it was just a bird, it was just a rabbit, or, you know, just get another cat, get another dog. This dismissive language, I think it's well-intentioned. It completely invalidates the intense pain of this loss. you wouldn't say that about the loss of a family member but all of a sudden it seems okay to be quite insensitive because it's just a pet they're lower on our humanity ladder it forces us into a
这是一种社会告诉我们“我们没有权力去感受”的悲伤。所以我们有点被迫在沉默中哀悼。你可能会听到远方的朋友或同事说这样的话：“这只是一只鸟，只是一只兔子”，或者“你知道的，再买只猫、再买只狗呗”。这种轻描淡写的言语，我认为它们的本意是好的。但这完全否定了这种失去所带来的巨大痛苦。你不会对失去家庭成员说这种话，但突然之间，表现得如此麻木不仁似乎是可以接受的，因为这只是一只宠物，它们在我们的人性天梯上处于较低的位置。这迫使我们陷入一种
painful internal conflict where our intense feelings of sadness you know kind of clash with the social narrative that says our grief is disproportionate or even foolish and this can make us feel like if we were to openly grieve and be sad, we would be shamed, we would be cringed at, we would be treated differently. You know, I have been in workplaces where someone has had time off for losing their dog of 16 years, and co-workers have literally rolled their eyes or made comments about it as though it is not significant. And I've genuinely never understood that because as a family, like my family always had pets. We had rabbits, we had guinea pigs, we had chickens, we had dogs. So the thought of not how having them, the thought of losing my beloved animal, the thought of losing Talu, like,
痛苦的内心冲突中，我们强烈的悲伤情绪与那种认为我们的悲伤是不成比例的甚至是愚蠢的社会言论发生了冲突。这可能会让我们觉得，如果我们公开悲伤，我们就会被羞耻、被鄙视、被区别对待。你知道，我曾在一些工作场所看到有人因为失去了养了16年的狗而请假，而同事们却真的翻白眼或对此发表评论，就好像这微不足道一样。我真的从未理解这一点，因为作为一个家庭，比如我的家庭一直都有宠物。我们养过兔子、豚鼠、小鸡、狗。所以一想到没有它们，一想到失去我深爱的动物，一想到失去塔鲁（Talu），就像
you guys wouldn't be hearing from me. The podcast would be on a hiatus. Research on pet loss reveals that the intensity of the grief, it can be comparable to the loss of a human family member. That is not ridiculous to say. A 2017 study found that pet owners can experience a grieving process when it comes to their pet with many of the same stages and symptoms as mourning a human, including depression, including anxiety, including a profound loss of identity. I'm aware that I'm probably focusing more on dogs than this episode because that is my main experience, but this could literally apply to any animal that you have as a pet. My cousin, she is, oh my God, I always forget what she is, not a marine, a wildlife biologist.
你们就再也听不到我的声音了。播客将不得不暂停。关于失去宠物的研究表明，悲伤的强度可以与失去人类家庭成员相媲美。这样说并不荒谬。2017年的一项研究发现，宠物主人在失去宠物时，会经历与哀悼人类相似的许多阶段和症状的悲伤过程，包括抑郁、焦虑以及深刻的身份丧失。我知道我在这一集中可能更多地关注狗，因为那是我的主要经历，但这实际上可以适用于你作为宠物养的任何动物。我的表妹，她是，天哪，我总是忘记她的头衔，不是海军陆战队员，是一位野生动物生物学家。
She's a wildlife biologist, coolest person out there. And she has every single animal that you can possibly imagine. Like, anytime I go to her house, like, obviously I love to talk to her, but I mainly just want to feed every single well taken care of pet that she owns. And at the start of the year, she lost her bird pipsqueak. Let me tell you, it may be just a bird to someone who doesn't understand that relationship. But like, she brought this bird back from the dead. and she hand raised this bird.
她是一名野生动物生物学家，是个超级酷的人。她拥有你能想象到的每一只动物。比如，每次我去她家，显然我很喜欢和她聊天，但我主要是想喂养她拥有的每一只得到妥善照顾的宠物。今年年初，她失去了她的鸟皮普斯奎克（Pipsqueak）。让我告诉你，对于不理解这种关系的人来说，这可能只是一只鸟。但是，她把这只鸟从死亡边缘拉了回来，而且她亲手养大了这只鸟。
She, like this animal meant something to her. It doesn't matter what the species is. It's the depth of the attachment that determines the intensity of the grief. When that attachment is severed by death and by loss, the pain is real and it should not be minimized. But for many, you know, this experience is complicated by a very unique and heavy burden. We are often in the position where we might have to make the course. of when it's time to let them go. We have to decide when it's the right time for our pet to pass on.
她，这只动物对她来说意味深长。物种是什么并不重要。决定悲伤强度的，是依恋的深度。当这种依恋因死亡和失去而被切断时，痛苦是真实的，不应被最小化。但对许多人来说，你知道，这种经历因一个非常独特而沉重的负担而变得复杂。我们经常处于不得不做出决定的境地：什么时候是让他们离开的时候。我们必须决定什么时候是我们宠物离世的正确时机。
It's an act of mercy, but it can be agonizing. This decision is always going to be one of the most compassionate ones you can make. It doesn't mean it's not going to be hard. And it can lead to such immense guilt and a sense of helplessness because this thing is completely reliant on us and yet we are doing the unthinkable. I know it is not an easy choice. And for those of you who have had to do it, I commend you. I can't imagine something so heavy.
这是一种仁慈的行为，但也可能是痛苦的。这个决定永远都会是你所能做出的最具同情心的决定之一。这并不意味着它不会艰难。这会导致巨大的内疚感和无助感，因为这个小生命完全依赖我们，然而我们却在做着这件不可想象的事。我知道这不是一个容易的选择。对于那些不得不这样做的人，我向你们致敬。我无法想象如此沉重的事情。
Sometimes I think about Talu dying and I just, I honestly don't think I will be able to bear it. Because it is just, it's hard. This is a weird tangent, but super weird. It will make sense, I promise. But my childhood dog, like I said, is super old. Like, he doesn't have much longer. And we've had him, like, my sister's 18. and we got this dog when she was two.
有时我想象塔鲁（Talu）死去，我真的觉得我无法承受。因为这太难了。这是一个奇怪的题外话，超级奇怪。我保证它会有意义。但我的童年狗，就像我说的，已经非常老了。它没有多少时间了。我们养了它很久，我妹妹18岁了，而我们是在她两岁时得到这只狗的。
Like she doesn't have memories without this dog. And I was so worried, like, how my sister's going to deal with this? Also, my dad, like, my dad and my dog are best friends. And me and my mom were talking about it. And we were like, do we get a rescue dog whilst YoYo was still alive to make the grief sting less? Or is that unfair for his, like, final years to be overshadowed? And then just a few months ago, this tiny kitten showed up. So small, so under.
她没有不带着这只狗的记忆。我很担心，我妹妹将如何面对这一切？还有我爸爸，我爸爸和我的狗是最好的朋友。我和我妈妈在谈论这件事。我们在想，要在悠悠（YoYo）还活着的时候弄一只救助犬，好让悲伤不那么痛吗？还是说，这样做对它的最后几年来说是不公平的，会被蒙上阴影？就在几个月前，这只小猫出现了。如此之小，如此体重过轻
weight, like so tiny. And I feel like I know my dog's time is coming, but this is like a little small thing, a gift from the universe that's like preparing my family and like showing that, you know, I think that animal is meant to be in their life for this next chapter. I still don't think I'll be prepared for it though. I feel like when he passes, when he crosses the rainbow bridge, like that's when I feel like I'm truly going to be an adult. A lot of people have told me that the grief of losing a childhood pet is actually like one of the most disorientating things ever because it just brings about such complex and weird emotion, waves of nostalgia, waves of mourning for your childhood.
太小了。我觉得我知道我的狗的大限将至，但这是一个小小的存在，来自宇宙的礼物，它在为我的家庭做准备，表明我认为那只动物注定要在他们生命的下一个篇章中出现。不过我仍然觉得我还没准备好。我觉得当它离去，当它跨越彩虹桥时，那才是我真正觉得自己成年的时刻。许多人告诉我，失去童年宠物的悲伤实际上是最令人迷失方向的事情之一，因为它会带来极其复杂和奇怪的情感、怀旧的浪潮以及对童年的哀悼。
Like your pets are like these silent witnesses to all these milestones, to you graduating, to your first job, to your first heartbreak, to your personal growth. And so losing a childhood pet, you're not just losing a loved one, you're also losing a tangible link to an important part of your past. It can feel like the definitive end of an error, the end of a specific version of our innocence, of our childhood, of our family unit. The sadness we feel is not just for the pet, it's for so much more. And I think that deserves a very compassionate space to be mourned.
你的宠物就像是所有这些里程碑的沉默见证者，见证你毕业、找到第一份工作、第一次心碎、见证你的个人成长。因此，失去一只童年的宠物，你失去的不仅仅是一个心爱的人，你还失去了一个通往过去重要时期的有形纽带。这感觉就像是一个时代的绝对终结，是我们纯真、童年以及家庭单位特定版本的终结。我们感到的悲伤不仅仅是为了宠物，更是为了更多更多的事物。我认为这值得一个充满同情心的空间来悲悼。
With all that in mind, let's talk about something more positive. Let's talk about the decision to bring a new pet into your life, especially during your 20s, a time of so much personal change. This is a decision that you have to think about. Like, you've got to think about it. You've got to be super sure. So we're going to turn our attention to the future here. What does a commitment to an animal truly entail? How do you know when you are ready?
考虑到所有这些，让我们谈谈更积极的事情。让我们谈谈把新宠物带进你生活的决定，尤其是在你二十多岁的时候，一个充满个人变化的时期。这是一个你必须深思熟虑的决定。你需要考虑清楚。你必须百分之百确定。所以我们将把注意力转向未来。对动物的承诺究竟意味着什么？你怎么知道自己准备好了吗？
Now, none of this is going to be about me trying to discuss. you from doing what's best for you, but I do want to really encourage you to just make a conscious choice that is going to be compassionate to both yourself and the animal. I also do know that dog shelters and rescue centers, for example, are completely overflowing. So it's important that this is a thought out decision. If you get a pet and you decide you don't want it, that's still your pet. I truly believe that is your pet until the day it dies. And so you are responsible. for finding it a new home, making sure it is taking care of, making sure that it has the life that it deserves. That is the worst case scenario you having to give your pet up. It's not a
所有这一切都不是为了试图劝阻你不要做对你来说最好的事，但我确实想大力鼓励你做出一个对你自己和动物都充满同情心的明智选择。我也确实知道，例如，动物收容所和救援中心已经完全人满为患了。所以这是一个需要深思熟虑的决定，这一点很重要。如果你养了一只宠物，然后决定你不再想要它，那它依然是你的宠物。我坚信它直到死的那天都是你的宠物。因此，你有责任为它找到一个新的家，确保它得到照顾，确保它拥有它应得的生活。最坏的情况是你不得不放弃你的宠物。这不是一个
light decision. So before you make the decision to get them, we want to minimize that as much as possible. I want you to ask yourself four important questions. Number one, depending on the life expectancy of your chosen pet. Do you have the financial stability for upwards of a decade long commitment? Listen, my dog cost $100. Like, in the grand scheme of things, that's not that much money. She lost $100. That, compared to how much I pay for her per month, is nothing. Her worming medication alone is $100 a month. Then it's another $100 for her dog food, probably more, to be honest, she's a big dog. It's probably a lot more. Plus the toys, because she choose through them all. Plus, three days a week, she goes to Doggy Play Group because I wanted to have friends and I wanted to
明智的决定。所以在你决定养它们之前，我们希望尽可能减少这种风险。我希望你问自己四个重要问题。第一，取决于你所选宠物的预期寿命。你是否有财务稳定性，来承担长达十年的承诺？听着，我的狗花了我100美元。从宏观角度来看，这其实不算很多钱。她花了100美元。与我每月在她身上花的钱相比，这根本不算什么。光是她的驱虫药一个月就要100美元。然后狗粮又是100美元，说实话可能还更多，她是一只大狗。可能要多得多。再加上玩具，因为她把它们全咬坏了。还有，一周有三天，她要去狗狗日托班，因为我想让她有朋友，我想让
have as much fun as possible in her short life. Obviously, that's optional, but pets are expensive. Ask yourself if you can afford not just the upfront cost, not just the food and the toys, but the unexpected vet bills, the annual checkups, pet insurance, any medications you might need over a period. of 10 to 15 years. Doggy daycare is there someone who's going to look after the dog if you can't? A sudden $2,000 emergency vet bill, because they found some chocolate on the floor, can put some serious stress on your life and an inability to pay for that, even more so. There's going to be significant guilt and heartbreak there. Pets will unconditionally love you, but they also deserve to be in a stable and financially secure environment if we're choosing to take care of them.
她在短暂的生命中尽可能多地享受快乐。显然，这并非必须的，但宠物确实很昂贵。问问自己，你是否不仅能负担得起前期费用、不只是食物和玩具，还能负担得起意外的兽医账单、年度体检、宠物保险，以及在未来10到15年里可能需要的任何药物。狗狗日托中心呢，如果你没有时间，有没有人会照顾狗？突如其来的2000美元紧急兽医账单，因为它们在地上发现了巧克力，会给你的生活带来沉重的压力，而无力支付这笔费用则更是雪上加霜。这会带来巨大的内疚感和心碎。宠物会无条件地爱你，但如果我们选择照顾它们，它们也理应生活在一个稳定且财务有保障的环境中。
Like they don't get a choice. They don't get a choice who chooses them. So if you're going to choose them, make sure you're thinking about them as well. And obviously things may change, but just with what you know now about your circumstances, are you making the right decision? Second question, does your lifestyle have a consistent routine? Pets, especially pets that need regular feeding. Again, I have no idea what lizards or snakes or stuff like that or even birds need.
就像它们没有选择的余地一样。它们没有选择谁来挑选它们的权利。所以，如果你要选择它们，确保你也为它们着想。显然事情可能会改变，但仅凭你现在对自身情况的了解，你做出了正确的决定吗？第二个问题，你的生活方式是否有稳定的规律？宠物，尤其是那些需要定期喂食的宠物。再说一次，我不知道蜥蜴、蛇或类似的东西，甚至鸟类需要什么。
I'm so sorry, but I'm thinking like the cat, dog, rabbit, guinea pig, hamster, fluffy vibe. Pets thrive on regular routine. They need regular walks, feeding times, attention, training. If you're someone who is constantly working late, traveling on a whim, has a very unpredictable schedule, you need to be honest about whether you can truly provide a stable, consistent environment for this living creature. something that made me so mad the other day was this guy on Instagram in a comment section asking for advice about his border collie. He has a border collie, a one-year-old border collie in an apartment. He lives by himself. He takes the dog out to go to the bathroom in the morning. Then he goes to
我很抱歉，但我想象的是猫、狗、兔子、豚鼠、仓鼠这种毛茸茸的氛围。宠物在规律的日常中茁壮成长。它们需要规律的散步、喂食时间、关注和训练。如果你是一个经常加班、心血来潮就去旅行、日程非常不规律的人，你需要诚实地面对自己，看你是否真的能为这个有生命的生物提供一个稳定、一致的环境。前几天让我非常生气的一件事是，Instagram评论区里有个家伙在寻求关于他的边境牧羊犬的建议。他有一只边境牧羊犬，一只一岁的边牧，住在公寓里。他一个人住。他早上带狗出去上厕所。然后他去
work from 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. goes to the gym, is not back until 8 p.m. and then takes it for a walk. and he was like, why is my dog tearing up my furniture? I would be tearing up your furniture if you left me alone in a house by myself for 12 hours at a time and only took me outside, what, twice a day? Maybe not even that, like, as an animal who was meant to be outside. And he was like, what do I do? Like, it's too late to ask that question. Obviously, like, people gave him actual advice, but this is one thing I have to say.
从早上8点工作到晚上6点，去健身房，直到晚上8点才回来，然后才带它去散步。他竟然问，为什么我的狗在撕我的家具？如果把我一个人关在房子里一连12小时，一天只带我出去两次，管它几次，也许还不止，作为一个本该属于户外的动物，我也会撕你的家具。而他却说，我该怎么办？问这个问题已经太晚了。显然，人们给了他实际的建议，但这是我必须要说的一点。
I don't have, I don't really like to give people unsolicited advice. This is the one thing that like really peaves me off. Don't get a working breed, a young working breed if you live in an apartment. Don't get a husky if you live somewhere that's hot 12 months of the year. Don't get a rabbit if you only have space for a tiny cage. Don't get a pet because of aesthetics. When you can't meet their needs. You know, I don't get really upset about much, but that really annoys me.
我没有，我其实不喜欢给别人不请自来的建议。这是唯一一件真正让我恼火的事。如果你住在公寓里，就不要养工作犬品种，不要养年轻的工作犬。如果你住在一年四季都很热的地方，就不要养哈士奇。如果你只有放一个小笼子的空间，就不要养兔子。不要因为美观而养宠物。当你无法满足它们的需求时。你知道的，我很少为什么事真正感到沮丧，但那真的让我很烦恼。
when I see people with an animal that is so clearly the wrong choice for their lifestyle. Like I live in Sydney. Why do you have a kelpie if you like work 12 hours a day and you don't exercise them? I literally, I can't, I don't understand. I'm like, why do you have a kelpie? Isn't that annoying? Like that dog would be going nuts. And I don't like to say, I don't understand everyone's circumstances, obviously.
当我看到有人养的动物明显不适合他们的生活方式时。就像我住在悉尼一样。如果你一天工作12个小时又从不遛狗，你为什么还要养凯尔派犬？我简直，我无法理解，我心想，你为什么养凯尔派犬？这难道不烦人吗？那只狗会疯掉的。我不喜欢说，我显然无法理解每个人的具体情况，
and maybe I'm making like, maybe I'm having preconceived judgments, but like for the amount of freaking kelpies I see in my neighborhood where there is like, like I don't understand it. I just don't get it. Like it's a living creature. If you have a specific breed or kind of pet you want, you can always wait. You know, it's just maybe not the right time to commit.
也许我在做，也许我抱有先入为主的偏见，但看看我社区里出现的那些该死的凯尔派犬的数量，真的，我无法理解。我就是搞不懂。它是一个活生生的生物。如果你有特定的品种或想要的宠物，你总是可以等待。你知道，也许现在还不是做出承诺的正确时机。
Wait till you maybe get a property. Wait till you have more money. Wait till you can, you know, pay for someone to maybe take them out when you can't. It will be more fun for you as well, and obviously for them when you can give them what they need. And it's not a constant stress of, am I doing enough? Third, I think this is a huge one. Are you emotionally ready to put something else first? This is a massive question.
等到你也许有了房产。等到你有了更多的钱。等到你能，你知道的，在没空的时候付钱请人带它们出去。对你来说也会更有趣，当然，当你能给予它们所需的时候，对它们来说也更好。而且不会整天处于“我做得够不够”的压力中。第三，我认为这是一个非常重要的问题。你在情感上准备好把其他事物放在首位了吗？这是一个巨大的问题。
Our 20s are a time for a lot of personal growth, and there's a lot of things you might want to do that you should be entitled to do. You should be able to travel, you should be able to have fun, you should be able to stay out all night. A pet, though, requires you to put their needs first. always. It means sometimes sacrificing a spontaneous weekend away or a late night out or travel to ensure they are cared for. It means being there for them and getting out of bed on your bad days even if you don't feel like it. This is a beautiful and selfless commitment. But it is vital to assess if you are truly ready and able to put another being's needs before your own for a prolonged period. Especially like a puppy or a kitten, you could not pay me to get a puppy.
我们二十多岁是个人急剧成长的时期，有很多你想做的事，而且你理应去做。你应该能够去旅行，你应该能够去玩乐，你应该能够彻夜狂欢。然而，宠物需要你把它们的需求放在第一位。永远如此。这意味着有时要牺牲说走就走的周末旅行、深夜外出或长途旅行，以确保它们得到照顾。这意味着即使在你状态不佳、根本不想动的时候，也要为它们出现，从床上爬起来。这是一个美丽而无私的承诺。但至关重要的是，你要评估自己是否真正准备好并在很长一段时间内将另一个生命的需求置于你自己的需求之上。特别是像小狗或小猫，你花多少钱我也不会去养一只小狗。
That is, it's like a child. It is literally like it's, you've got a, you couldn't pay me. It's a lot. Are you ready for that? Lastly, are you getting a pet for the right reasons? And this is something that I had to ask myself as well. Are you getting a pet to cure your loneliness? Are you getting a pet because it's like an aesthetic thing? Are you getting a pet because you can imagine the next year and how much fun it's going to be, but nothing beyond that? A pet's a great help with loneliness. Trust me, I work from home. I was so lonely before I got Talu. Has she cured it for me? No.
那真是，就像一个孩子。它字面意思上就像是，你有一个，你花钱也买不动我。这太繁重了。你准备好面对这些了吗？最后，你养宠物的动机正确吗？这也是我自己不得不问自己的问题。你养宠物是为了治愈孤独吗？你养宠物是因为它是一种美观的装饰吗？你养宠物是因为你能想象未来一年会有多好玩，却完全没有考虑之后的事情吗？宠物对缓解孤独确实有很大帮助。相信我，我居家办公。在养塔鲁之前我非常孤独。她治愈我了吗？没有。
And relying on her, relying on them for your own happiness, like we said, there's an emotional relationship. They feel that and it puts an unfair burden on them. But also, you know, you'll likely get them and be like, whoa, this isn't as amazing as I thought it was going to be. And that's a hard position to be in. The best reason to get a pet is a genuine desire to care for and build a life. life with another being, not as a quick fix for your emotional needs. There's also like other
而且依赖她，依赖它们来获得你自己的快乐，就像我们说的，这是一种情感关系。它们能感受到这一点，这给它们带来了不公平的负担。但同时，你知道的，你很可能会把它们接回家然后感叹：哇，这可没有我想象的那么棒。这是一个艰难的处境。养宠物的最好理由是对照顾另一个生命并与它共同生活有着真诚的渴望，而不是把它当作满足你情感需求的速效药。如果你意识到自己并不适合养宠物，还有其他的
options if you realize pet ownership isn't for you. For example, family or friends have a pet, you could offer to pet sit for them for a while. Not only will they likely be very grateful. It means you can actually get used to like what this is going to require. It also means you can hand them back and you don't have to like, you don't have the guilt of making a long term commitment. It's like when people want me to hang out with their babies. I'm like, absolutely I will do that because I don't have to take this baby home. Like, same thing with a pet. I also had a friend who literally did not pay rent for a full year because she did pet sitting gigs.
选择。例如，如果家人或朋友有宠物，你可以主动提出帮他们照顾一段时间。他们不仅可能会非常感激。这意味着你可以真正习惯照顾宠物到底需要什么。这也意味着你可以把它们送还回去，而不必承担做出长期承诺的内疚感。就像人们想让我跟他们的婴儿玩一样。我的态度是：当然可以，因为我不需要把这个婴儿带回家。宠物也是同理。我还有一个朋友，她通过帮人看宠物，整整一年都没付房租。
That's another option. There are so many sites where people will be like, you can live in my house for free if you look after my animal. Many local shelters also really need volunteers. and they literally need volunteers to play with the animals or to simply just like sit with them in their cages. This is like a really nice way to give back and to receive that like animal led joy.
那是另一种选择。有很多网站上人们会说，只要你照顾我的动物，你就可以免费住在我的房子里。许多当地的收容所也非常需要志愿者。他们确实需要志愿者来陪动物玩耍，或者仅仅是坐在它们的笼子里陪着它们。这是一种非常好的回馈方式，也能收获那种由动物带来的快乐。
Also something I highly, highly recommend is fostering. Obviously didn't work out for me the way I wanted to. I ended up getting a dog but if you met her you would understand why like she's a once in a lifetime. But dog shelters are quite literally overflowing. They always need support and a lot of dogs. aren't going to do well in a shelter. Same with cats. Getting them out of that environment is just going to do wonders for them and it's going to increase their chances of being adopted as
此外，我强烈、强烈推荐的一件事是寄养。显然，这对我来说没有按我想要的方式发展。我最后还是收养了一只狗，但如果你见过她，你就会明白为什么她是一只千载难逢的狗狗。但动物收容所真的是人满为患。它们总是需要支持，而且很多狗狗在收容所里过得并不好。猫也是一样。把它们带出那样的环境会给它们带来奇迹般的改变，并且会增加它们被领养的几率
well. It's a defined period of care. Also normally all the shelters like the rescues will pay for the food bills, the vet bills, they'll give you toys. It's like amazing. It's like the best of both worlds. And finally, because I'm not done with giving unsolicited advice about pet ownership, If you are thinking about getting a dog or a cat or even like a rabbit or a guinea pig or a chicken, like whatever, please consider going to the shelter first. And please read up on responsible breeding. There are so many misconceptions about rescue animals out there. You have no idea the work that these places put into these dogs and these animals to make sure that they go to loving homes.
这也是一段明确期限的照顾。而且通常所有的收容所，比如救助站，都会支付食物费、兽医费，还会给你玩具。这太棒了。这简直是两全其美。最后，因为我还没说完关于宠物饲养的不请自来的建议，如果你正考虑养一只狗、一只猫，甚至是兔子、豚鼠或鸡，随便什么吧，请先考虑去收容所看看。并且请阅读有关负责任繁殖的知识。关于救助动物有太多的误解。你根本不知道这些地方为这些狗狗和动物付出了多少努力，以确保它们能去到充满爱的家庭。
I would say 95% of the time they are like, they are absolutely perfect. And if you want a specific breed, which I totally get, I can guarantee you there is a rescue organization that specializes in that breed and takes on people's pets of that breed that they don't want any more to rehome them. And it's not going to cost you like $4,500 that you're going to pay to someone who you have no idea what their intentions are. I just think secondhand, secondhand dog, secondhand cat, third hand dog, third hand cat. Like, it's, I think it's fine. I really think that they end up being amazing animals. So I think that's all that we have time for today.
我想95%的情况下它们都是，它们绝对是完美的。如果你想要一个特定的品种，我完全理解，我向你保证，一定有一个专门针对该品种的救助组织，它们会接收人们不再想要的该品种宠物并为它们重新寻找家庭。这可不需要你花4500美元去交给一个你根本不知道其意图是什么的人。我真的觉得二手的狗、二手的猫、三手的狗、三手的猫，都没问题。我真的认为它们最终都会成为极好的动物。我想今天我们就只有这么多时间了。
And I hope that you have learned something about this deep connection we have with the furry critters in our lives, whether you have one or not, whether you want one or not. I hope that checklist of questions maybe either confirmed something for you or made you realize that, you know, that's something for you to look forward to. I loved making this episode. I'm just going to, like, dedicate this to Talu. I love her so much. Is that a surprise? Probably not. But I had such a joy recording this. So thank you for listening. Leave your pet's name down below as well, like I said, especially if they had a human name. I also want to thank our researcher Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode and for her amazing work as always.
我希望你通过这期节目了解到我们与生命中那些毛茸茸的小动物之间有着怎样深厚的联系，无论你是否养宠物，无论你是否想要养宠物。我希望那份问题清单要么为你确认了某些想法，要么让你意识到，你知道，那是你可以期待的事情。我非常喜欢制作这一期节目。我只想把这一期节目献给塔鲁。我太爱她了。这算是个惊喜吗？可能不算。但我录制得非常开心。所以感谢大家的收听。正如我所说，请在下方留下你宠物的名字，特别是如果它们有一个人类名字的话。我还要感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本期节目的贡献，以及她一如既往的出色工作。
If you want to learn more, if you want some behind the scenes content, if you want summaries of episodes, you can follow us at that psychology podcast on Instagram. make sure that you are following us here on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, the IHart Radio app, wherever you are listening, and give us a five-star review if you feel called to do so. It really helps the show reach new people. It's an amazing free way to say you appreciate us as well if you do. I don't know if you do, but if you do, thank you. Until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. Go and put some loving on a cute little puppy out there.
如果你想了解更多，如果你想要一些幕后内容，如果你想要节目的总结，你可以在Instagram上关注我们：that psychology podcast。确保你在Spotify、Apple Podcasts、iHeart Radio应用程序上关注了我们，无论你在哪里收听，如果觉得有必要，请给我们一个五星好评。这真的对节目接触新听众非常有帮助。这也是一种极好的免费方式，用来表达你对我们的认可，如果你确实认可的话。我不知道你认不认可，但如果你认可的话，谢谢你。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。去给外面可爱的小狗狗一些爱吧。
Go to the dog park this afternoon. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
今天下午去遛狗吧。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。欢迎收听我的播客2%。
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理坚韧、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听2%。也就是数字2%。
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，那对对我来说是个大日子。1984年对我很重要。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。1984年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《从难处学起》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关注黑男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to Learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有多少男人身披盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《从难处学起》。这是一个iHeart播客。人类品质保证。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。